what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and Avengers Secret Wars actually isn't
that far away phase four is now complete
and we're about to jump into phase five
in February with Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania which is going to kick off
the Kang Dynasty and Avengers Secret
Wars the way everything has been right
now and laid out in front of us it does
look like phase five and phase six are
going to be better for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe than phase 4 was
although phase 4 did give us some
amazing projects a lot of fans are
really looking forward to Phase 5 and
then phase six Kang the Conqueror is
surely going to be a fantastic villain
especially with Jonathan Majors playing
him he's already done an amazing job
with the character as he who remains and
Loki and so far the way he has portrayed
king and the Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania trailers has been
fantastic so certainly the next two
phases and the next handful of years are
going to be fantastic however I do
believe something even more exciting
awaits after and that is the age of the
Fantastic Four and the X-Men with
villains like Galactus Dr Doom Magneto
and nihilus so many classic heroes and
villains are going to be coming to the
MCU and the MCU is going to completely
change after phase six so I have a
theory of how phase six is going to end
and set up phase seven and I
particularly think that this is going to
happen either in the post credit scene
or at the very end of Secret Wars after
the final battle has already taken place
and the Avengers save the universe
because let's face it that's probably
what's going to happen now Marvel could
hit us with a curveball and kind of
reset everything but even that is
probably going to be considered a
victory for the Avengers considering the
fact that the alternative is Kang ruling
the entire Multiverse so the question is
how exactly will the King Dynasty and
Secret Wars end well apparently
according to our buddy Paul over at
heavy spoilers The Kang Dynasty is going
to end very similarly to Avengers
Infinity War much like Thanos 1 and
Avengers Infinity War and the Avengers
were defeated at the end the that's
pretty much going to happen for the King
Dynasty Kang is going to succeed with
his plans and Conquer many different
worlds and many different universes this
will lead to Avengers Secret Wars where
our heroes will have to go throughout
the Multiverse Gathering other Heroes to
come together and defeat Kang something
we are all very very much looking
forward to however something that fans
are very much looking forward to as well
are the X-Men but sadly it doesn't seem
like we're going to be getting a new
X-Men team before Secret Wars which
leads me to my theory today the
post-credits scene for Avengers Secret
Wars or the ending will set up the
actual mutant team by hintinet or
introducing Professor Xavier and or
Cyclops now there is a lot that has
actually come out either reported by
Major trade Outlets or simply some
information given to us by Marvel
Studios themselves that point to the
X-Men coming after Secret Wars but
Secret Wars being the big setup for them
and before you think that there aren't
going to be any X-Men in secret Wars
don't worry we'll talk about that and
there will be just perhaps perhaps not
what you think you see I think I know
exactly how the mutants will be
introduced in this post-credits scene
you see an Avengers Secret Wars and any
other movie that would come before then
that would travel the Multiverse and
explore variants possibly the Kang
Dynasty and keep in mind there are two
movies scheduled between the King
Dynasty and Secret Wars so those two
movies could be movies all about
exploring the Multiverse and Gathering
an Avengers team at the very least
they'll introduce us to new characters
and variants who could go on to join the
big multiversal Avengers team so in all
of these movies where we go to other
universes and see other variants we are
going to see X-Men variants this is
already confirmed and there's a lot of
talk about how the old original X-Men
are going to be the X-Men team in secret
Wars and there's a reason for this
according to some reports that have come
out the X-Men are still kind of tied
under a contract with Fox to make things
very simple Marvel Studios can't exactly
use any new X-Men characters yet however
they can use old X-Men characters anyone
from the old Fox Universe this explains
why we haven't seen any new X-Men yet
and also while we saw Patrick Stewart
still playing Professor Xavier and
Multiverse of Madness not that anybody
is complaining about that it was amazing
to see him return although I am kind of
sick of watching him die so throughout
all of the events that are going to take
place in the MCU leading up to Secret
Wars and then in secret Wars our
Avengers team and the people from our
main Universe are going to come in
contact with X-Men and with mutants and
there are even mutants in our universe
right now Namor is confirmed to be a
mutant Miss Marvel Kamala Khan she's
confirmed to be a mutant as well of
course they'll be in secret Wars but our
main Universe won't have an actual X-Men
team it'll just be a bunch of mutants
and other X-Men from other universes but
here's where the post-credit scene comes
in our Avengers and our Fantastic Four
are clearly going to work with other
Fantastic Four members and other X-Men
members so after this is all said and
done after they finally defeat King they
can't simply go on and ignore the fact
that other enhanced individuals AKA
mutants people who were just born with a
genetic mutation exist plus not to
mention Doctor Strange met the
Illuminati he met some of the most
powerful characters in The Multiverse
although you wouldn't really think that
based on how they fought Wanda but those
Heroes seemingly don't exist in his own
Universe at least he's not aware of that
in which case he needs to explore and
find them the same thing is going to
happen after Secret Wars and I believe
the post-credits scene is going to be
some key Avengers who are going to be
sticking around or maybe even saying
goodbye talking about how they need to
find their universe's variants of the
X-Men so imagine Patrick Stewart's
Professor Xavier fighting with our
Fantastic Four with our Avengers team
and all of our other heroes from our
Universe imagine Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine imagine Cyclops after Secret
Wars the people in our universe are
going to want to find the variance of
these amazing Heroes asking the question
do these people exist in our universe
and do they have the same powers are
they good are they evil there are many
different reasons why they should seek
out and find these people either because
they can help them or because they could
actually be a threat however that won't
be explored until phase seven but we
know Marvel Studios Marvel is going to
start with phase seven immediately after
phase six so the post-credits scene is
going to be something that is going to
set up the mutants most likely somebody
mentioning Professor Xavier's School for
gifted youngsters mentioning Charles
Xavier or Cyclops and here's why I think
it'll probably be these two mentioned or
hinted at in the post-credit scene
Charles Xavier is pretty
self-explanatory if you're familiar with
who he is he's the leader of the X-Men
and his name is also in the title of the
school Xavier's School for gifted
youngsters and he's one of the most
powerful mutants of all time he is a
classic and iconic X-Men not to mention
he studies and has posted papers on
mutations so if you were researching
mutants in a universe his name would
definitely pop up however there have
been some rumors that that Cyclops could
actually be the leader of the new mcu's
X-Men team rumor has it that Marvel
could go down this path to be original
since we've already seen Professor
Xavier and his X-Men in the fox universe
and what's very interesting about this
is that some concept art for Miss Marvel
that was released after the show came
out showed a scene of Avengers con and
it showed Cyclops or it showed somebody
dressed up as Cyclops at least which
means Cyclops exists in the MCU and
what's even more interesting is that
this person was dressed up as Cyclops in
an X-Men uniform we can clearly see the
X-Men logo here which would imply that
an X-Men team does already indeed exist
in the MCU otherwise it wouldn't have
the X-Men logo that is why I believe
that Cyclops could actually be the
person mentioned in this post-credit
scene and could actually be the current
focus of Marvel for the new Mutant Saga
and I think this is what is going to
start the mutant Saga which I believe is
going to be phase 7 phase 8 phase 9 and
however many phases they want to include
include in the mutant Saga and it just
kind of makes sense for them to set that
up for the future of the MCU at the end
of Secret Wars or in the post-credits
scene so that is my theory but let me
know what you think about it in the
comments down below do you think the
next Saga is the mutant Saga and if so
do you think the ending of Secret Wars
is going to set it up leave your
thoughts down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe stay up to date
on all things relating to the MCU for
live updates you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof